what was the tipping point where the
venture capital community
embraced this idea and how did you get
them on board because i know you raised
like a 30 million dollar round and
before that you'd raise like 10 or
something
how did you raise the money for this
idea because let's face it
um people were kicking you out of
locations they were taking your picture
and posting it at the security desk
don't let this kid in again uh with your
crazy idea
yes did vcs do the same thing or did
they think you were crazy like a fox
um yeah yeah and it's just interesting
um
so i actually really never um wasn't
familiar with the vc world like i was
like a small business entrepreneur
salesman kind of
uh and based in chicago um and so when i
got started
it was really like um i'm going to build
a a nice small business like this is it
could be
impactful but um i was lifestyle
business
yeah like exactly i want to solve this
problem but it can it can be a nice
little
like organically growing business and
all of a sudden
uh the demand took off and what i
realized is that uh the business needed
a bunch of infrastructure to scale
um and i needed to raise capital so i
actually um
read the book like how to be smarter
than a vc
and uh because actually someone wanted
to invest in the business they were like
you have no idea what you're doing read
this book
and then i've never heard of this book
how to be smarter than a vsa was it good
yeah it's great it's like that if you
google like uh vc yeah it's like the
number one seller on amazon perfect
um and and you so i read this book and
then i
built a pitch deck and i went around and
and
actually uh you know we had like
angel investors and and people like that
in chicago
um but i got i got really lucky we met
with a vc
group that happened to be in chicago for
the weekend and
visiting some of their lps and they i
fed them lunch and i thought it was kind
of just like a meet and greet meeting
and they made an offer on the spot wow
um and so
very unusual situation we had a couple
of um angel investors lined up and they
said don't
don't go that route you need to go the
vc route um
and i went home i talked about it with a
bunch of people and and decided that
that was the right path but then
we really didn't fit the mold of a
traditional vc business
no at all and so it was very difficult
for the next round to you know get
people especially
um where they they sort of actively
don't want you to own things or move
stuff around or do like operations
they're like making a marketplace
sell software to other people to make
machines do not take this on yourself
yeah exactly and we're sort of saying
like everything about this business
because we haven't talked about it a lot
but we we actually
make all the food we distribute all the
food
and we own so we own the whole
experience from end to end
right and we're literally cutting
avocados on the line making dressings
from scratch like that's what makes the
product so good
it's full stack it's fully integrated
because you have
this new format it's got to be done to
your specification i mean of course you
could outsource it
but if you outsource it then that
product is being optimized for a
different reason than customer delight
exactly it's being optimized so that
co-packer
can put in the worst low-quality
avocados
to make money off of your customers as
opposed to getting your customers come
back
exactly that's like and and they're
actually trying to amortize their r d
across like five different customers or
20 and so they're they're selling your
your hard-won
ideas to someone else right you're
educating people exactly
so the slice is like no we have to do
this and so actually for our second
round
most vc investors were like this is nuts
you have no chance of success
um and good luck and
so they told it to you like that uh well
you interpreted that
in different ways some people were
direct some people just never got back
to me but you got the message right
when they said it in a direct way i'm
curious how did they phrase it like what
was the
most candid way somebody phrased it the
most brutal
uh you this is not a vc business you
should like you know not even think
about it
right don't raise venture capital
exactly and then which is actually like
a good advice and actually i was gonna
say like he was very direct but he's
also a close friend
and and someone who i like he actually
um
worked at redbox and was um like the
first person
that educated me on how to build this
company like had one fridge it was
working
and uh he happens to be a vc and so i
went to him to get money and he was like
no
no i'm saying exactly i'll help you but
i i couldn't invest in this because i
mean
what is why do you think vcs don't like
your business
well so i think it's changed well why
did most not like it initially
and then why do they like it now yeah so
i think initially
um it was really this idea that you had
to
have physical infrastructure and the
scaling was going to be hard like we'd
hear that a lot like how are you going
to scale this up
and you know it just seems too hard and
there's all these executions so the
infrastructure and the complexity of the
business made it easy for venture
capitalists to say no
yeah and but you got that first uh slug
of capital who
who is that bold vc who deserves credit
for
uh when they zip through chicago on the
lp meeting uh it's a firm called great
point ventures
great point ventures as opposed to bad
point ventures great
never heard of them where are they based
uh they're based here in san francisco
great yeah wow
big fun medium-sized fun it's about a
200 million dollar fund they're now in
their second 200 million dollar fund
ah it was their first phone when they
invested in yeah we were looking for
their first investment
i tell this to founders all the time oh
my god the best thing for a founder is
to find a first-time fund you know why
why because they need to put the money
to work they had no track record and
they're going to have fresh eyes and
they might want to try something
yeah we say it the way we say in the
industry is they might jump the fence
they might take a risk right yeah i
think that's true i think they
they were they were looking at this and
they were saying we've got a lot of time
and we can make a bet you know a few of
these
like small high-risk bets yeah um and
especially early in the life cycle
whether it's their first bond or early
in the fund i think they're more open to
that for sure how did you convince
the old sirs the people who've been at
venture capital for three decades four
decades
two or three four decades to you know in
their own fund five or ten
to come in and invest in what you're
doing so
i think really what changed is we were
able so we showed we could scale the
company so we had actually scaled into
chicago we were now at you know 150
on our way to 250 it was undeniable the
transaction was undeniable yeah it was
in a lot of the
initial objections about like can you
scale this up or is it a fad
uh you know we had proven we'd taken a
lot of the
those things out of it and we'd actually
shown
that we were able to leverage the data
that we were collecting
to optimize the menu and and create uh
like really compounding like 3 4x growth
and so it was like oh this is actually a
really compelling unit model
you are disrupting the way that food
gets to market
and in an environment where uh
restaurants basically have rising retail
like all every cost is going up so the
retail apocalypse
not being able to get workers workers
minimum wage going up the competition
for workers who are hitting the gig
economy and saying well why would i go
do a shift at this restaurant when i can
do uber whenever or lyft whenever i want
and i have to deal with the boss
dragging my ass into the same location
just pop in my car do a couple
rides get out go to the movies and do a
couple more rides or pick up my kids
like
it's hard for a fast food restaurant to
compete against uber lyft and other
alternatives because they pay more right
exactly
yeah you have no boss really the whole
thing that people
miss about the gig economy is not having
a boss
because bosses are a-holes almost
universally
i'm listening over there i'm listening
over there i'm listening over there in
the engineering room
but they are and not having a boss is so
nice and delightful you feel agency in
your life there's nobody coming in
telling you what to do
and but that was a big headwind against
these restaurants here in san francisco
the mid-tier restaurants are starting to
put kiosks um
ipads in and kiosks and you're like wait
this is a restaurant not with a
tablecloth but this is a restaurant with
a 20
entree yeah and i'm ordering from an
ipad
really yeah and then you do it and
you're like thank you yeah that was like
it was really
famous i was really annoying to have
this like
20 year old like actor be really pissed
off at me for their life and having to
be a waiter and then get my
order wrong because they're not paying
attention like it's so nice to use that
kiosk
yeah so i think that that's a good
example where you had these um
outside forces starting to converge so
like what we had been saying
for three or four years now it was very
obvious like the business could scale
you're seeing people move to kiosk
ordering um the unit economics of like
delivery had become more clear so there
was a bunch of startups that when we
were just getting started out here
that were doing like individual drops
and through like postmates you mean and
stuff like that yeah but like actually
making the food and dropping it off
yeah we had a company we invested in
called bento okay then there was a that
was doing pre-prepared meals to your
home for
12 bucks and you really had to charge 15
an entree to make it work but it was a
really hard
business exactly food waste etc yeah and
so people kind of got it all together
yeah